we literally just got the biggest iphone
14 lineup leak but before i show you
guys this new photo of the iphone 14
lineup i want to mention that a lot of
people are already disappointed they are
saying that it's ugly and they can't
believe apple is doing this but i want
to make it clear that i completely
disagree and i think everybody is wrong
but jumping right into this photo from a
source that was leaked on weibo as you
can see we have the official
iphone 14 lineup display
panels now this is a really big deal
because it confirms the exact situation
with the bezels the dual hole punch
cutout the thinner earpiece speaker and
the awesome thing is that shrimp apple
pro also confirmed the leaks of these
iphone 14 lineup molds as you can see
these molds show off the differences in
the camera bumps and these bumps are
massive and now with that said let me
answer the question of why everybody is
wrong about the dual hole punch camera
looking worse than the notch well first
of all greg's gadget made a very good
point when he showed what everybody
thought about the leaked iphone 4 design
as you can see people are saying that it
looks hideous short answer no it looks
horrendous fake ugly no way however
people loved the iphone 4 design after
it actually came out and it was in
people's hands and i think the exact
same thing is gonna happen this time
around in september when they finally
launch people start using them people
start experiencing the screen real
estate difference they're gonna love
that apple made this change to the pro
models first of all you can see a clear
difference in the bezels and you get a
lot of extra screen real estate in this
area and finally this image probably
shows it off the best look at all of the
extra screen real estate we got a pretty
awesome leak from miksha quo saying that
the front camera of the four new iphone
14 models is gonna have an upgraded
selfie camera with auto focus and
faster aperture f 1.9 and as far as the
rear camera once again mark german
agrees that we're getting 48 megapixels
on the pro model and then finally the
last detail i want to share is that the
new color we're getting for the iphone
14 pro is a new darker purple which is
unfortunate because i didn't really like
the sierra blue and i wish we would get
this new bronze because i mean look at
it it looks beautiful